thank you so much for that warm
introduction first I just want to thank
you all for attending can everyone hear
pretty well that's it going in the back
alright fantastic so we're going to talk
a little bit about the DARPA Memex
project which is a and but first we have
to talk about what the Deep Web is so
when we look at the internet we go to a
commercial search engine we ask the
internet a question who do you think is
answering you it's probably a business
right but has a business model in mind
when they're trying to produce search
results that are going to get you to
click on things they're going to sell
you advertisements they want you to be
able to look at the most popular things
that are coming up in page ranks and
things like that
they want you to see what they want you
to see right because we are all looking
at the internet through a little bit of
a filter and so we can't really judge
what the quality of the data is that
we're getting back or how much the data
that we're getting back how complete the
results that we're seeing what they
might look like so when you actually a
lot of people don't even seem to realize
when they're looking at data oh I've
seen estimates ranging everywhere from 5
to 15% of the visible Internet is what
it's actually is so 5 to 15% of the
Internet is what is visible when you're
moving through a commercial search
engine I think that probably around 10%
is more accurate but basically there's a
ton of data that's available below the
surface that maybe not necessarily
indexed it could be behind paywalls it
could be on sites that are trying to
hide their identity there could be a lot
of things going on there right so when
we look at the depths of the Deep Web
we're looking at about you know I think
that these these estimates are a little
out of date but if we're looking at
about 19 terabytes of content in the
visible web we're looking about 7.5
petabytes of unseen data that's
available below the surf
there's a lot of data there that can be
used in order to gain insight into
various activities inside the Deep Web
there's a subset of pages that we're
going to call the dark web and these are
pages that are intentionally hidden or
people are trying to purposely hide
their identities and they're trying to
do business in such a way that there is
a completely obfuscated who is involved
both on the buying and selling side or
who on the browsing and the serving side
and the goal of the Memex project is
actually to look at these regions that
are not necessarily usually looked at so
many of you probably heard about Silk
Road this is something that was
happening in the dark web where
basically somebody set up an illegal
drug trafficking site that was available
where people could buy drugs there are
also several charges of murder for hire
that were not carried out but these were
the allegations that were against the
creator of Silk Road there was the Silk
Road version one Silk Road version two
I've even heard of Silk Road version 3
but the government has gone after sites
like this in order to shut them down so
we're going to talk about the DARPA
Memex project so what we're doing here
where we realize that for government use
cases the web search use case the normal
one-size-fits-all search is not really
going to work for most government
agencies they need to be able to look at
deeper levels of the web they need to be
able to search and index into parts of
the web that people are not necessarily
looking at right now Darkman launched
this program in September of 2014
they're about 17 teams that are working
on this continuum analytics I'm the
co-principal investigator for the
continuum analytics team and we were
actually on two of those teams so we
work with both NASA JPL kitware on one
side and then on the second team that
we're on we're in the NYU Cornell and
continuum team so what we're doing here
we're trying to develop software that
advances online search capabilities we
want to be able to point crawlers in
places of the internet that are not
traditionally indexed by commercial
based search engines we want to produce
weights to look at that data understand
what's in that data present that data
and search that data to make it
available to those who might be able to
use it so we're creating this new
domain-specific indexing and search
paradigm where we want to be able to
discover new content we're looking to
improve information extraction
information retrieval techniques and
then we also want to encourage user
collaboration one thing I'm going to
harp on quite a bit during this is that
this is an open source project which is
pretty progressive for DARPA they're
they're funding open source projects
that are working on these problems so we
want to basically the idea is that we
want to increase our current search
capabilities to look at the Deep Web the
dark web where we have the you know
identities are hidden but then we also
want to be able to look at
non-traditional content so if we're
looking at pictures or multimedia rich
text formats
so even Excel spreadsheets powerpoints
things like that that might end up on
the web we want to be able to index all
of these and search them and find
information from them so the idea here
we're pulling together basically the
traditional web scraping technologies
we're interacting with high-performance
computing we need to be able to use
machine learning in order to be able to
focus our searches and understand what
relative content content looks like in
order to help law enforcement agencies
bring down people who are doing illegal
things on the Internet so some of the
search domains that were working on we
actually for the last year and a half
there's been quite a bit of effort on
the human labor trafficking side of
things this one includes a sex workers
so crawling for
information on Backpage identifying
victims who may be involved in
organizations that are trafficking them
across different areas I think maybe
some of you may have seen some of the
press for the Super Bowl this last year
there were a record number of sex
workers trafficked in for the Super Bowl
this year and actually the internet
helps makes this possible because people
are able to actually they can estimate
the demand they can set things up ahead
of time people are able to respond to
classified ads they're able to to move
things pretty seamlessly and also move
funds seamlessly across the internet one
thing to also mention the human labor
trafficking domain that's very
interesting is there are a lot of search
capabilities and images has come out of
this domain where we're actually able to
tag different pictures of of different
victims of this exploitation so we can
catalog pictures but we can also search
for them across different sites so we
can see the movements as people are
being moved from location to location
we're able to find them we're able to
document information about them or even
able to pull things out of the pictures
we're we're able to find locations we
can document whether or not they're any
props or whether or not a room has been
used in other pictures we can also
catalogue things like identifying
markers like tattoos and things like
that which is actually pretty common
practice in when people are selling
humans they might tattoo them with their
particular organizations sign or
something like that which can help us
identify who is actually moving the
people this is also we're partnered with
the ATF looking at weapons traits
material research science where we're
looking for different materials that are
being moved in different areas
particularly anything that may have any
kind of military application financial
fraud so we're partnered with the SCC
pulling in lots of financial information
looking at front-running or
pump-and-dump
for people who are moving or basically
inflating the price of stocks
manipulating the market and then dumping
the stock
and basically taking people for a lot of
money and say it's a huge problem it's a
huge manipulation of the market in the
first place but it's also a extremely
important vector for money laundering so
they want to be able to identify this
and stop it
counterfeit electronics this one is not
so much looking for people who might be
just creating electronics and selling
them you know with the you know the
wrong name or something like that you
know may have like the Apple version of
a particular phone or something like
that but they are looking for
electronics that are entering the u.s.
supply chain that may interfere with
military operations so in particular
looking for espionage backdoors and
counter and also counterfeit electronics
that have sabotage triggers incorporated
into them which may put other people's
lives at danger not to mention it's also
just a huge amount of waste when the US
military is wasting money on counterfeit
electronics that they can't use actually
out in the field patent trolling so
looking for companies that may not
necessarily have a lot of revenue but
have a ton of lawsuits filed against
different people and also you know
intellectual property infringement
things like that and possibly the most
heartbreaking domain that we work on a
child exploitation so much like working
with the human trafficking and labor
trafficking documenting and and and
finding information about children that
may be exploited and missing and there
are other search domains I'll actually
mention a couple of them while we go
here but these are just a sample of some
of the different domains where these
different technologies can be applied so
as I mentioned before these are open
source tools so we're looking here this
is a Forbes article that came out where
it actually has a screen shot up here of
Digg which is one of the other teams
that we work with us from the USC where
they are finding information you can
tell that this is for the human
trafficking
where they're cataloging pictures of
different workers that may be
advertising on on Backpage or on other
site similar to that and then also just
to mention all of these are cataloged on
the DARPA open catalogue so all of the
open source projects that are out there
are available on this open catalogue and
if you actually search under Memex
you can find the ones that are
particular to this domain and so there's
a lot of good information there a lot of
different organizations are involved
here it takes a huge amount of effort on
everyone's on everyone's part in order
to pull all of these things together so
I just want to talk a little bit about
the overview of the ecosystem for a
large-scale data analytics platform so
we're talking about basically indexing
into huge amounts of data on the
internet or pointing crawlers across and
pulling data from all the nether regions
of the internet puzzling it into indexes
and making it searchable this is a huge
challenge so when we look at what it's
going to take in order to build a
platform that can do this we have to
integrate several different disciplines
right so we have distributed systems we
have the BI database so business insight
database more traditional relational
databases and then scientific computing
and data mining stats and machine
learning we have to pull from all these
different things so on the on the
database side we're working with MongoDB
SQLite SQL alchemy Postgres MySQL these
are things that people have probably all
seen before these are all open source
and available for people to use oops
wrong way on the data mining side and on
the machine learning side we're using r9
cycads learn pandas Waker we have quite
a few different pieces that are coming
together in this platform so we're using
a whole lot of different technology
throwing it at this problem scientific
computing we're looking at using numba
blaze which is another a continuum
project number which is also from
continuum
hdf and pie tables and then in
distributed systems for looking at
backends that are gonna sit on top of
Hadoop and spark hive and Impala so and
then there's some crossover between
these different pieces where we're able
to interact between the different the
different disciplines so mahute
obviously people are probably familiar
with that we're using that for machine
learning in order to train models that
are used for directed crawling and then
also our Hadoop is available so our
analytics pipeline is actually kind of
simple it's very similar to what you
would expect when looking at a
commercial search engine so we send out
web crawlers and scrapers that go out
and collect content we want to be able
to from to extract entities so we're
pulling features out of these pages so
when we're looking at a semi-structured
text on a web page we can pull out
buying and selling information phone
numbers addresses payment information
images anything that might be
identifiable but we are trying to stay
above the network layer so we're not
looking at I P addresses and things like
that we're really just looking at
content on this side because we found
that especially for areas where people
are office skating their identity the IP
address you know server information
things like that those are ephemeral
they're going to change they're going to
go away very very quickly and they're
not good identifier for finding people
out though who are doing who are
involved in these these activities now
we have indexers involved here where we
take all the information and make it put
it into an index and then on top of that
we want to add some visual analytics so
we can tell what sort of information
that we've actually collected so our
team at continuum analytics is mostly
responsible for Memex Explorer which is
a pluggable framework for crawling and
data discovery it's built on Django so
it is a django web application you can
interact with
we have elastic search index on the back
side so we're putting everything into
elastic search for search ability we
have bouquet visualizations for looking
at crawling stats and also for looking
at information about what you've
collected
in your data and then we're also using
Cabana dashboards I can't say enough
good things about these dashboards I
don't know if you've ever looked at them
you can just point them at an elastic
search index and visualize data is super
fast it's amazing and I'll do a
demonstration showing that later then
the different crawlers that we have
integrated so far into MMX Explorer are
the Apache non-touch crawler and then
from NYU we have the shake crawler which
is both of these have directed crawling
capabilities so we can actually upload a
classifier that will direct crawling
into different areas and/or also
classify out links whether or not we
want to follow out links and and follow
that information deeper into the web and
then on top of that we also have the NYU
domain discovery tool and that allows us
to basically take a really simple search
but then be able to expand it and be
able to train classifiers based on
information that we're actually manually
marking relevant or irrelevant as we're
looking at the information that comes up
so just want to mention so our partners
over at NASA Jet Propulsion Laboratory
are our Pachi developers so they're all
working on nuts and teeka there the
teeka project I think is particularly
interesting because it has the ability
to do first pass extractions on the
information that we're grabbing from the
web so we can pull and this includes
rich content actually so it can take
image information give you information
about the camera that took the photo
right you can find information about it
do automatic translation you can do on
different pages you can find author
information on Docs or powerpoints and
things like that it can pull out a lot
of information from different page
sources including I mean I mentioned you
know Docs powerpoints PDFs all sorts of
different document types so we use that
as a first pass to pull information and
content out of this of the information
we're collecting off the web and this
gives us it kind of puts everything into
a format and that's its standard right
we know what fields are going to come
out of teeka we have the idea what sort
of text
expecting and that's what we use as our
first pass there are other extractors
that it may go through pass this
pipeline right so I mentioned dig
earlier from USC that's another
extractor that we put put pages through
so that we can pull out author
information your publication things like
that
and then I also wanted to mention on the
NYU side these are open source projects
as I mentioned before so ah Cheh
and the domain discovery tool are both
available through github so this is a
screenshot and that makes Explorer but I
always think it's a little bit more fun
and more adventurous to do a live demo
alright so here's my mix explore the
idea here is that we have different
projects these would correspond to the
different domains that you're looking at
so if you have a law enforcement agent
that wants to look at information wants
to direct a crawl wants to find
information on a different domain the
idea is that they would start a project
here and this would be kind of the
beginning of their at their exploration
it's also at the beginning of their
investigation into a particular group
and the idea is that they can hold all
the information about this particular
exploration to one location that they
can then come back to I'm going to start
over here in patent trolls actually and
I'm gonna start with the domain
discovery tool it's gonna take a minute
for it to load up here but what we're
looking at here this is already
pre-populated you don't necessarily have
to have pages that are pre-populated I
just do this for demonstration purposes
but you can also basically start with a
web search here put in the key terms
that you might be looking for so in the
case of like maybe so we're here patent
rolling you may look for key terms that
have to do with patents guaranteed you
know intellectual property things like
that where you're able to put key terms
in here get back results and then we're
looking at the the pages this is just a
distance based metric of how similar the
pages may be to one another but then we
can come through and actually select
portions of the
pages you can't see that that very well
but these pages are coming down here
where you're able to see a preview of
what is on the page right and and then
the idea is that's from this preview you
would be able to tag it as being
irrelevant or relevant or if it's a just
neutral
it may have relevant information it may
not it may not be that important but it
may also have some really nice terms in
it that you want to be able to use and
so once we have okay I'm going to come
back out there
once we've you can see here once we've
we've labeled our different pages as
being relevant or irrelevant we can look
at the key terms that come up here and
what's nice here is also as I scroll
over these you can see that the the text
so you get a little bit of context of
where this term came from from the web
page you can see information that may be
relevant around it it's to turn to
determine whether or not this is
actually a key term that you're
interested in and then ultimately as
you've now created labels for all of
your data just hit this model button
here right and it's going to train a
train a classifier for you so in this
case we're actually do defaulting to a
naive Bayes classifier we're just using
a bag of words model very very simple
just regular keywords terms and then
once we have this model file put out
we'd be able to come back to mimicks
Explorer and out of crawl we give the
crawl a name down here we specify which
crawl model we want to use so we're
going to direct our crawl based on their
relevant irrelevant tags that we've
added to the pages already and then
submit it it'll go out crawl the web for
as long as you want it to pull
information back in index it into
elastic search and then you'd be able to
visualize it through the dashboards one
of the nice things that comes out here
also I think I actually had it set up
for this one but over here in autonomy
here's a crawl that was already done I
guess last week you can see here these
are bouquet plots where we're looking to
see
scroll statistics we want to see how
well our crawl did so we can see out of
all the pages that it visited what is
our harvest rate what are the pages that
we found interesting when were the ones
that were classified as being important
to us and to our domain pull it back in
and those are the that's the information
that ends up in your index right when
you look at this particular classifier
by the way you may notice that you know
how many are relevant how many are
irrelevant things like that this doesn't
look like a particularly compelling
model if you may look at like how much
was crawled and then how many things
that we found to be relevant that's
pretty high we're looking at about a
ninety percent harvest rate we may end
up retraining or changing our labels or
something like that in order to bring
that down because I really do want to
just grab the relevant information that
is going to most help law enforcement
agencies in order to build cases against
people who are involved in these
activities so going back to my slides
you can see that that screenshot of
mimics Explorer there I just want to
mention some of the tools that are used
here so this is built on the Anaconda
platform switch the Innoko it's a
continuum analytics product it's free
it's available for download it's kind of
akin should see kicks kitchen-sink it
included Python distribution this also
has a Conda involved it incorporated
into it which is our package manager all
of the packages that are involved in
mimics Explorer are available through
Conda so you can kinda install nuts you
can call it the install pika you can
kinda install any of these different
tools including domain discovery tool
even you can just kinda install them I
also want to mention blaze this is
something that is really important
because working across 17 different
teams as you can imagine people are
pulling data from all over the internet
putting it into different backends
they're putting it you know all sorts of
different formats and things like that
we try to standardize as much as
possible but especially when somebody's
you know one person is using HBase
another person is using HDFS another
person is using elastic search we do
like to have can
frontend to be able to manipulate data
and blaze provides that for us when
we're able to actually do in database
operations do compute pull things out
move things into data structures easily
and and and reduce our amount of code
actually and then I just wanted to
mention that blaze has this you know
computational back-end as I mentioned
before so we can do in database
operations we've data storage and
abstract expressions so that we're able
to succinctly describe what we what sort
of manipulations we want to do on the
data also wanted mentioned boquete which
is interactive visualization so I'll do
some more demonstrations in a minute
with okay but definitely wanted to
mention it because it has made it very
easy to be able to interact quickly with
our data and show results to people
especially if their particular parts of
the data that they're interested in they
can kind of hone in on those parts
without having to worry too much about
revealing I don't know as sensitive
information classified information this
is an unclassified project right where
we're looking at data or we don't
necessarily know exactly how they do
their investigations we're just
collecting data and making available
providing search tools for people I also
want to mention scikit-learn fantastic
product right and so being able to train
the classifiers I did mention wake up
before and the hoot but we also use I
can't learn in order to train
classifiers we get depending on the type
of model that you're using you may find
that some packages work better than
others or you may get better performance
from different projects so when we're
looking at data analysis we've now
collected all of this information right
we've indexed it we have it somewhere
you have no idea what's in it right
nobody's going to go through and look at
every single one of these pages that was
crawled nobody wants to look at each one
of those pages individually and
determine what sort of information is in
them
but we do want to be able to look and
see what we have right so a really good
way for us to do this is to provide
topic modeling on top of this so when we
look at text on on webpages we can do
this is an unsupervised
a procedure where it's basically
clustering based on words right so we're
looking at there are different ways to
do it without getting into the specifics
of how to topic modeling works the idea
is that we're clustering information
from documents into different topics
that may be relevant to that particular
domain and when you do that you get bat
weight there are different ways to look
at this this data I'm actually going to
break out of this and go to another
demonstration this is for the the
material sciences side I have the the
screenshots as a backup just in case my
internet connection flaked out on me
you know but the idea here this is from
material research science you basically
you know took about 70,000 documents and
index them which is not a great you know
it's not a huge amount of data this fits
in memory we're able to you know do
manipulations on it pretty quickly but
for a proof of concept this is a is a
good way to to explain what's going on
but we can see what kind of terms are
showing up in each one of the topics so
the x-axis represents the different
topics that were found in in the data
and then the y-axis represents all the
key terms that are associated with that
particular topic topic you can see here
that there are some that are shared
across different different clusters you
can kind of see how that works and it
gives people an idea of what sort of
information is in the data that's been
collected the one thing that I do want
to mention I mean that's the challenge
in using topic modeling in order to look
at data is that there's not really a
good way to map what these topics are in
relation to how you might describe them
to somebody it's not like you can say
like oh these are all related to you
know a nuclear technologies or these are
all related to some other technology or
something like that there are different
ways that we've looked at in order to
see them to try and make that a little
bit better but we've also found that
generally the we lose a lot of
performance in the clustering algorithms
when we try to seed them and try to
manipulate that too much so it's still
an open problem but
but this still gives people a general
idea what's in there related to this
also in the topic topic modeling side
and we're using Lda
under the hood in order to to do our
topic modeling and so when we have this
Lda visualisation package this is
actually from an r package called LD
Avis and this is a really cool
visualization where we can look at the
different topics involve what key terms
are available and then how it relates to
the total number of occurrences of that
key term across the entire corpus so you
can kind of see what the co-occurrence
are what sort of percentage of your of
your key terms are wound up in that
particular topic and then you know just
explore each one of these as you move
through and then I also just want to
mention the word cloud app I think that
this one is a little bit I was a little
surprised actually that people find this
to be so helpful but some people really
like seeing key terms in pretty pictures
I guess but as you can see here I mean
is this particularly helpful riot films
definitely kind of dominates the picture
here but we can put stop words in here
and then we can also filter out kind of
our lowest percentage and our highest
percentage of words to kind of get a
better idea what's in here let's say
that we're going to go ahead and put
this in two intervals so we want to look
ahead and see how things have changed
over time and then update it
so here you can kind of see how things
have changed over time it might find
some keyword terms that would be useful
to you that might be interested that
point to papers or point to information
that you would find interesting in this
particular domain when we come back to
these other tools that are over here I
was mostly talking about what my team
has been working on but one thing I did
also want to mention our partners over
at JPL put together this facet space
demonstration this is on the same
collection of documents and so here
taking those keyword terms that you
found from the unsupervised processes
that we put all the papers through you'd
be able to add these search terms here
and then find facets of information and
then actually get back to the papers
involved that actually describe those
particular pieces of information and
then as I mentioned before I also just
wanted to mention Kabana dashboards as I
said this is freely available I'm just
amazed how quickly you can build
visualizations here and they're
interactive right so as you move through
here you can actually look at different
trending information so we're looking
here by country who's been who's been
publishing in material science over time
and you can see different jumps in
different countries and things like that
obviously it's mostly dominated by the
United States here and then down here
also tagging different papers with
keywords so in this case if there were
particular materials that people were
interested in looking at you'd be able
to look and see which countries are
involved in research for those
particular materials that that are
tagged in the different documents it's I
think it's a really great way it's
amazing like I said before you know
putting this dashboard together
basically took about 15 minutes you can
put all of this together point it to
your elasticsearch index it walks
through how to do visualizations and
then you don't have to write any d3 you
don't have to write any code it just
automatically puts it to get
and you can save it out into a dashboard
so coming back here right so I also want
to mention some of the technologies that
we're using as I mentioned before on the
back end we're using elastic search and
Cabana is also available through elastic
Beco if you're ever interested in
playing around with that I just wanted
to thank you for your attention
and if anybody has any questions
definitely let me know
over here so the question is who has
access to this technology and it's this
ice since it's open source everyone
right so everyone can use it I think the
data is proprietary right because that's
very sensitive I mentioned you know
these demos that I showed you are very
that's not sensitive material there's
not anything all that damaging in there
right but you definitely but the
technology is available to everyone
thank you
well I think okay well I'll first start
with your first question right so um
talking about if we have access to
special tools that allow us to index
into deeper parts of the webs or
different parts of the web than other
people and that really that's the
information retrievals teams have
developed technologies that do allow
them to move into spaces that other
teams can't as they can they have to
develop their own technology in order to
do it but we do have crawling teams that
work specifically in like tour sites
things like that and moving into parts
of the web that are not necessarily
indexed and then how does this program
differ from some of the other programs
out there like NSA and things like that
I think them I can't really speak to
that so much I think because I am NOT
the program manager on that but I did
want to mention you know I think that
one thing that's definitely very
different here is just the fact that
this these are open source tools right
so this is democratizing search and
making it available to anyone who might
be interested in this sort of technology
and making the technology available to
anyone who might be interested
some sites do I'll just put it that way
yeah so especially it's some storefronts
and things like that especially when
you're looking at goods that may be sold
in particular domains do have
information about different methods of
payment that are available or different
with links to places that you would have
to go in order to make a payment so
that's kind of information that we can
index anyone else over here I'm sorry
one second over here
so the question here is are we looking
at interpreting information that's in
blockchains I actually I don't know
about that
I'm afraid over here that's where the
domain experts so the question is how do
we determine the difference between
people who are legitimately trying to do
business and those who may be bad actors
out on the web and this is where the
domain experts come into play we
actually you know search and kind of a
you know collect as much data as
possible way right but the domain
experts they're the ones who can
actually Cole the data and tell us you
know whether or not this is relevant or
irrelevant the idea is to give them
tools in order to be able to work
through that that flow easily because
right now a lot of investigators are
really you know they're sitting down at
their browser clicking through sites
manually you know trying to keep track
of information in an Excel spreadsheet
or something like that and we just want
to make sure that they have better tools
in order to find information they're
looking for
back here
I'm sorry what was the question one more
time oh sure we actually do use spark by
the way in our tools I was talking about
particularly what my team was doing
people are definitely using spark ml
that I mean there are other teams that
are definitely using it for the topic
modeling actually recently one of our
developers added spark support for that
because obviously we're working with
these huge sparse data sets and sparse
matrices of information and spark works
really really well as a back-end for
that it's probably something that we
should look into in the future but up to
this point those packages have been
sufficient for our needs
anyone else
all right thanks - oh one more
yes extractors are on that webpage I
don't think that they add the fields
that they're looking at and how they
actually extract them that would
obviously be sensitive right to let
people know what sort of information is
being collected but the framework is out
there all right thanks again for your
attention and also just wanted to give a
shout out to my team they're fantastic
they do amazing work and work really
hard on this project and it's a pleasure
to work with them thank you thank you